you ever have a moment in your life
where somebody says something you hear
something a song the scene something
that happens the words that come out of
someone's mind that completely shakes
your soul up your spirit up that you
you're absolutely in a different place
thinking about the possibilities it's
what happened to me about three years
ago and I want to share that story with
you so in 2014 late 13 2014 I started
losing my voice and in my business I've
run a financial firm so I have to talk
if I can't talk I can't negotiate I
can't challenge I can't push I can
encourage I can't teach I can't sell and
it started getting worse so initially I
thought it was just a sore throat that's
not a big deal it's gonna go away then
everybody would ask me Pat what's up
with your voice I've been doing
conference calls and I can barely say
anything then I'm doing events and I can
barely speak and one time I was on a
tour and I'm on the ending on my tour I
have to go from LA to Miami from Miami
I'm finishing it up in Hawaii and while
I'm in LA I just couldn't even talk
anymore
my wife's asking you got to go get the
distinct on so I go to the doctor and I
meet with one of the best doctors and
sitting there I don't really know if
anything's wrong with it or what's
what's what he's gonna say maybe he's
gonna put a spray or something like that
I'm gonna be good so I go to this doctor
and I sit down he's going through this
whole procedure next year he brings
another person and another person and
they start doing on and you know bring
me this bring me that bring me this and
I'm like wait a minute I've never seen
this kind of reaction from a doctor and
I say doc is everything okay he says
well give me a minute let me find out
and then he asks everybody to leave and
he says hey um what do you have going on
next week I say next week I'm speaking
of Miami now speaking in Hawaii so
there's nothing I can do about it
he says I think you need to cancel this
I can't cancel I have to go out become a
twin of Miami Oh Hawaii says this is a
little bit more important than a
speaking engagement I said no I kind of
got to do it I said well what's your
point he says well this doesn't look
good and so what doesn't look good he
says you know typically when I see what
I'm looking at right now it's cancerous
and if it's cancerous this thing spreads
very very quickly here and it could have
pretty bad effects on you and I said
really it says yes I said come on you
know pause
thinking it's not going to be anything
says no this is something you ought to
take very serious we need to do surgery
fairly quickly and I said okay so I come
back and I can't tell you know the
company because it you know have to do
what I have to do so I keep my
commitment I go to Miami I come back I
go to Hawaii and in Hawaii I mean people
who were at that meeting in Hawaii I can
get a word out it was probably the worst
talk I've ever given in my life come
back from Hawaii I'll and the next day
Monday a four o'clock in the morning I
go in they set me up they do the surgery
they cut me and I said what's going to
happen he says for one month you want me
to be able to speak and this surgery was
done on November 23rd so I think about
the number 23rd Thanksgiving is a
following week and I have family all
these people that are coming over and
you know Thanksgiving you know kids
nephew knees playing gresling eating I
can't speak for one month okay and my
brother-in-law knows I like the singer
name daughter huge it's a Persian singer
when I was a kid living in Iran I just
always listened to his song because his
songs are very very emotional he was
somebody that wasn't happy with the
government and he sang songs with his
frustrations with God and people and
many many different things but you know
he became a drug addict and never wanted
to talk about the fact that he had some
drug habits habits bad habits and then
eventually he became came public about
it started a nonprofit organization I
think today he's got about one point
nine two million people role your lawyer
your loyal fans that follow this man
around the world and CEO Mac told me
there's a concert in Orange County I
want to take you to it I go to it and
he's about 70 some years old and he
starts singing my favorite song and by
him it's called the ahoy Mohammed
Danielle what he's saying is go
something like this
oh ho ma domi dona
ahoy Mars Amador when yo Gila daughter
Gila daughter manners dusted fedora
Gila daughter killer daughter and then
he goes she won't give home anybody he
sings the rest of it but what he saying
is I'm frustrated with God because why
is it that the people in the world have
put a price tag on love and why is it
that we're doing this he's sharing his
he's been very vulnerable with the
message he's given so he sings this song
and I'm absolutely emotional because I'm
remembering living in Iran with my mom
dad still together before the divorce
and the war were being bombed and at
least we're living together eatin food
the whole culture everything you're on
was so and then he gets up he says I
want to say something to all the young
people in the audience and he says I
want to talk to the young ones the 20s
30s 40s he's known to and 40s is young
because he's 70 something and he says I
want to tell you something you don't
have as much time as you think you do
and what I want to tell you is this just
make sure the young wolf in you takes
care of the old wolf that you're one day
will be I said what I was I was just
leveled by that statement so just make
sure the young wolf in you take security
hobo because one day we're all gonna be
in all voices I'm an old wolf now since
I don't have the young wolf anymore and
it's as if that moment I was lost I was
completely lost in a different world
and I started visualizing the 75 year
old version of me
how would he walk how would he talk
would he even give his opinion would he
get up with back problems would he put
his hand on his knee when his getting up
what would he be doing what would be his
frustrations how would we talk to me
right now if I could talk to this guy
what'd he say Pat come on get your life
together I need you I need certain
income when I'm at that age I need to be
taking care what would it be saying to
me and it made me realize that how much
we think we have all the time in the
world and we don't time has gone by very
quickly and I was in Chicago this past
week and I was talking to an audience
and I said I want you to look at your
hands and everybody looks at their hands
like this as a no no no on this side we
all look yeah I want you to look at your
hands here because this always tells you
right
so I started everyone's looking at the
answers I look at the wrinkles I said
the join hands like look like that 10
years ago start looking at every single
thing yesterday I had about 20 people
over on my house on Sunday I was
mentoring these guys and I'm sitting
there in shorts and honest and I noticed
the inside of my foot had these blood
you know blood vessels that pop you know
what I'm talking about
I said I've never seen this before but
I'm getting older I've never seen this
before
what's this body gonna look like at 70
75 and the challenge I give to the folks
in Chicago is you don't have as much
time as you think you have you don't you
know the question sometime is important
to ask is 10 years ago five years ago
did you think you'd be in the financial
position you are today um most people
say no I thought I'd be a million out
that I'll be making a quarter million a
hundred thousand whatever it is so why
aren't you why don't you question that
and what makes you think the next five
10 years is going to be good the way
you're going right now don't you think
it's time to change some habits don't
you think it's time to be a little bit
more real about life and not just look
for a bunch of motivational videos
really face the truth and realize that
you're not giving everything you got
wanting to be real with yourself when is
that account it was gonna be taking
place because I was telling this group
you said on my house I said look I've
never been as frustrated as I was in 20
in 2003 August when I just sat down and
said I'm so disappointed with you pat
you've been winging all your life and
you got to get your act together
so the message in this video is very
simple be sure the young wolf in you
today is taking care that old wolf in
you one day and visualize it let it
bring a little bit of pain and urgency
in you because we ain't got as much time
as but as we think we have so that's
what I wanted to share with you there's
no real message behind it about
entrepreneur seven points to do this
just want to share my heart with you
thanks for watching
oh oh